so we're a little protein hunt right now
and we get some Mozy meals in lots of
protein really cheap on the go for
anyone this guy you got like 30 35 grams
of protein to this protein nuts
chicken breast oh you don't have any
grilled at all
sad face
oh hold on found us a treasure Trove all
right tune of Creations 17 grams of
protein no carbs basically no fat so
this whole thing has 110 grams of
protein people were like I can't keep
protein I'm like you bag of this
what we're looking for is stuff that has
40 or higher uh protein by calorie
content
hello can I just get a double serving of
the uh grilled chicken would it be
possible for you to give me a triple
serving 900 calories 108 grams of
protein one meal on the go onwards on
the hunt I think I'm gonna get a two
pound box a pound of that's gonna be
berries and a pound of that's gonna be
turkey pound of berries it's like 150
calories I might just eat this for
dinner
those meals